do it to do it if you're thinking of
starting a business you should do it
because what you're doing is important
you're doing it to do it you're not
doing it because you're just trying to
make a lot of money you're not doing it
because you want better work-life
balance you're not doing it just to have
control of your destiny you're doing it
because it's important because it needs
to get done because it's missing because
you have an opportunity to change the
world to have a massive impact that's
why you're doing it if you look at every
successful I'm talking big time
successful entrepreneurs okay not the
guy who can can you know work half a
week and then enjoy the half of week
doing something else with his life the
people who are making it big the people
who are big time entrepreneurs having a
huge impact looked at why they did this
you look at why they started their
company is cuz they saw something that
they needed to do they're not doing it
because they want to make money sure
that's part of it but you don't see any
entrepreneur say I'm starting this
business to make a lot of money the ones
who do don't say that don't you really
believe that they never make money the
guys who are out there just to make
money never make money the guys are out
there who are trying to make a
difference they make a difference they
changed the world and in the process
make tons of money money can't be your
only goal if that's your goal you won't
succeed you have to have something else
why are you starting this business
people will say they're doing it because
they want control their destiny or
because they want to work fewer hours
they want to better work-life balance
and that's great okay so you can go from
working 40 hours a week for somebody
that you hate to working 25 hours a week
doing something that you hate as well
but you have 15 more hours of the week
to spend on whatever you want is that a
happy life is that what you want to do
you know doing something that you you
hate maybe a little bit less than your
job but just working fewer hours you
shouldn't be running away from work work
shouldn't be the evil so you can spend
more time traveling or with family or
whatever it is you should be inspired
and everything that you do the goal
isn't to spend less time working to
spend more time
here the goal is to spend every minute
of your life doing something that is
exciting for you that is passionate for
you that drives you forward that makes
you feel like you're doing something
important that it's changing your life
and the people around you and so when
your invest in your time no matter how
much time it is into your business you
should look forward to that you should
be doing things that are important to
you that you're growing that you're
helping people that's why you start a
business it's not just a cut down the
amount of work hours you have the people
who are out there with part-time
businesses that support them so they
could travel the world or whatever you
get bored of that trust me you do that
for a year or two you get bored that
you're you search for meaning people
want meaning in their lives people want
to feel like they're doing something
important with their lives and the
people who are happiest who are most
fulfilled are the ones who are taking
every minute other life and doing the
most with it and that's in your personal
life and also in your business life your
business should be something that fuels
you that gets you excited that gets you
passionate like it's you're feeling
something that's why you do it that's
why you start a company and you'll make
money in the process and you can work on
your work-life balance if that's
important to you but the work part of
your work life should be amazing too it
shouldn't be something that you run from
this in response to a question that came
from one of my readers who's the fund is
ill I don't know I hopefully I didn't
butcher that name too much writes to me
and I'm thinking of starting a poultry
company because in my opinion is a
fairly cheap businesses start this is
the totally wrong reason to start a
business you don't start a business
because it's a cheap company to start
you don't start a business because it's
an easy business to start you start a
business because you see something that
is missing in the world and you're going
to fill it do you know anything about
chickens do you love chickens you wake
up dreaming about chickens you have
another revolutionary way to to raise
chickens I don't know you gotta love
chickens you got to be the chicken guy
if you are the chicken guy and you love
chickens
you have a new way of doing things and
thinking about chickens excites you then
that's the business to get into and
you're not doing because it's easy
you're not doing it cuz it doesn't cost
a lot of money you're doing it to do it
you do it because you love it chickens
are your life that's going to be what
you're all about there's a lot simpler
and less costly businesses are getting
than chickens chickens you have to you
have to buy the chicken you got to have
the food you got to have the places for
them to sit there's a lot of cheaper
businesses you can get started but it's
got to be something that you love that's
a differentiator you love it you'll be
successful you'll pour yourself into it
you do it to do it that's so important
it's critical it's everything before any
other business tip I can give you I can
tell you how to be successful in your
chicken business but if you don't love
it you won't go through all the crazy
hurdles you're going to have to go
through to get to success the most
successful entrepreneurs in the world
are the ones who plowed through so much
pain and darkness and when people are
telling them that they were crazy and
you should stop but what are you doing
you're not you're killing yourself over
this thing why why are you doing this
because I love it because I have to
because it has to get done no no matter
what gets thrown in my way I'm going to
push through that's what successful
entrepreneurs do and the only way you'll
have the energy to do it is if you love
it you have to do it even even if you
weren't getting paid to do it because
you love with someone you take on jobs
just to provide an income for you and do
what you were doing for free because you
love it that much that's a difference we
do raise chickens because you love
chicken so much if not you're in the
wrong business you got to find something
that you love at the start finding a
business that you're passionate about
can be really tough it could be a goal
of yours to want to start your own
business but it's the most important
decision of anything that you're ever
going to do in your company it's going
to be the most important thing what are
you starting this thing around why are
you here what are you trying to do you
figure that out and you have the roots
of a highly successful and profitable
business that can not only change your
life but that people around you
your community your country potentially
the world depending on how much you're
willing to give to it so if you're
starting a business it's not about how
easy it is it's not about how cheap it
is you're doing it to do it you're doing
it because it's important do it because
it's right you're doing it because it
needs to get done that's why you're
doing it believe for those are you
watching like the video please give it a
thumbs up it always makes you want to do
more for you and I want to hear what you
have to think please leave a comment
underneath I love hearing what you guys
write it makes my day really like I feed
off of your feedback it keeps me going i
love it coming in so please leave a
comment underneath and if you have a
question you have a struggle with your
business you want my advice on it leave
it in the comments below i'm a good
video response thank you so much and
I'll see you soon